I sure come on in don't don't mind the
dog I'm thrilled with the dog okay gang
first how are you some of the day I'm
thrilled with the dog rate you're
writing all these down I am do I have to
put these on yes no great phone call
well take it okay you want to do so wait
am i wait a minute real quick just to
set the tone you have a gold mic and
everybody else doesn't
I'm the pompous ass I'm excited to be
here Gary uh first of all Charlemagne is
a very dear friend of ours yes when he
found out you're gonna be on the show
he's like you're gonna love Gary Vee
he's great
we had a lot of fun together and he's a
really sharp dude he is and he's off on
his own and doing so well so many
different things and he gives you a lot
of credit that's super nice but uh but I
think his hustle and his ambition has a
lot to do with it but I'll take any any
credit I don't deserve any day of the
week let me let me just start up the
lawnmower real quick yes you tell me if
I'm right or wrong do I want to move on
to some other things go ahead Gary a
born and raised born in Belarus in the
former Soviet Union and raised in New
Jersey raised in New Jersey first came
over to Queens lived there for two years
and I mainly grew up in Edison New
Jersey your parents your father had a
wine store yes my dad came here with a
hundred bucks lived the American dream
eventually became a stock boy manager
and then eventually bought a store in
Clark New Jersey called shoppers
discount liquors and then opened a store
in Springfield New Jersey I was a you
know entrepreneur lemonade stand
baseball card shows in Phillipsburg Mall
Bridgewater Mall like it's fun to do
this show obviously a lot of locals and
then and then eventually my dad dragged
me into the store and I revolutionized
the wine industry by launching one of
the first e-commerce wine business is
called winelibrary.com
and built up one of the biggest wine
shops in America over in Millburn in
Springfield Short Hills New Jersey even
those who don't know a lot about wine
which is most of us you can watch Gary
in the old days when he was doing these
videos he's doing these Wine Library TV
white wine lab TV show it's like a
normal average guy trying wine without
going oh it's called through undertones
and overtones of you know socks you
would drink wine ago yeah there's
good yeah we buy it Elvis that was a big
thing so YouTube came out so I was right
about e-commerce I was right about
Google AdWords I was right about email
marketing and then YouTube comes out and
I'm like this is gonna be big and so
four months after YouTube started in
2006 I started Wine Library TV and and
everybody who's listening right now it
you know just think to yourself do you
know somebody that's into wine and I
think most people are gonna say yes and
what everybody knows is that the second
somebody just gets a little bit of wine
knowledge they become a straight jerk
right right like oh you're drinking the
wrong year right or you didn't smell
that properly and I was a Jersey kid
that came from not a whole lot but I
knew an obnoxious amount about wine cuz
I grew up in the business so when I
started Wine Library TV I just referred
to wines the way I grew up like this
smells like a Hulk Hogan wrestling
figure or this is like a racquetball or
this is like you know big league for
example a lot of Cabernets smell like
big league chew chew wine fun and
approachable and now wine because of you
a lot of people give you credit wine has
become a major major business for all of
us I think I think that's I think that's
overstated but why do all the crap not
this I'll take a little bit of Shahs
credit but what I will say is this I no
question created wine drinkers in the 20
year old demo 21 and older demo at a
time where most people were talking down
to people about wine I was talking with
people about wine now I don't want this
to become all about wine there's okay
just how Gary Vee got into where he is
and he took an idea which you can apply
with almost anything in life and turn it
into something huge going back to the
days when you were a kid selling a
training baseball card yes he he would
go to these trading trade card shows or
whatever you call them yeah where he had
lots of competition a lot of people have
much better cards to sell and trade and
make money from but he just found a
different way to do it which made him
become the leader as a kid in this
little bitty industry you knew nothing
about but look what you did so what did
we walk away from that learning and how
can we all apply it for a lot of people
that are listening right now I think one
of the you know it's funny the way you
just position that the truth is I was a
DNF student right so Martin Luther King
School in Edison New Jersey north
hundred in high school and in hundun
County those teachers did dating
see this coming and and so what what I
realized was this is what I was good at
right I was good at looking at things a
little bit different than everybody else
I was good at telling stories I was good
at selling I was good at really working
much harder than anybody else in the
things that I was most interested in and
so what I was able to do in a time in
the 80s and 90s when it wasn't as cool
right now being an entrepreneur is cool
right
it's cool everybody wants to be a CEO
and an entrepreneur when I was getting
these and F's I was making $3,000 a
weekend as a 14 year old but my teachers
and my friend's parents didn't think I
was a winner because the scoring back
then was about school yeah and so what
the one thing I would take away from
this is everybody's listening and
driving right now is look you can decide
to choose what the market says is cool
now or you could try to figure yourself
out and disproportionally triple down on
what you're good at
well the good example here is it who do
you know other than Gary who was a C D
or F student but because they just
didn't thrive in a preset like the
tester already written for you society
but when they came out of that and could
make their own rules come up with their
own test for themselves they could
thrive and fly like an eagle and that's
the thing when you live by other
people's rules you're not gonna give
yourself a chance to take a step back
right now and think about who we all
admire in the world right they're all
people that punted the system they're
people that practice singing since they
were five there are people that shot ten
thousand basketballs every morning it's
always that it's always that 99% of the
people right now that are listening to
this are playing in the middle they're
playing in a game that was structured
for them the risk adverse they fear and
most importantly they fear what other
people think that was I think the best
thing that ever happened to me much like
you with your gold mic I didn't care
what other people said and and it's not
because I didn't respect it I actually I
get feedback all the time that might be
negative this is I respect it I listen
to it but at the end of the day I'm just
not built to have it dictate my one
at-bat at life okay how do we apply it
yeah have you always been like that
that you had to learn I think a little
bit of both look I got very lucky I
think you know not coming for much is a
huge advantage you know I'm writing a
book in my head right now that I would
venture eight right called I wish
everybody was an immigrant when you come
from nothing when you come from zero
when you have to walk two miles to Kmart
in Dover New Jersey you know that's
that's an advantage right so you know
not many people would think that's an
advantage yeah until they look around
and they look around and realize all
these immigrants on all these businesses
right like like when you realize how
great America really is you know right
now we're living through such a new time
right and everybody wants to tell you
how bad it is and there's so much
there's always things that are tough
like I'm very lucky I was born in a
different place I travel a bunch like
nobody's moving to Canada or Mexico so
quick right nobody's moving somewhere
else this is a special place and you can
either choose to look at the small
percentage of bad things or you can
choose to look at the far majority of
amazing things that happen in this
country and that's what I choose to do
and I think once people realize all the
opportunity and realize first and for
most of us nobody's going to care about
your complaining like I love when people
complain like who who's gonna care and
so how do you apply it it's a mindset
right have I always had it look I had
the benefit of having a mother who's the
greatest in the world that instilled so
much self-esteem in me that peer
pressure and negativity never even got
close to the center of my soul right I
got lucky that way but I found yourself
I found myself I think you know it's
funny and I remember it was like fourth
grade I got an F on a science test and
for some unknown reason I mean remember
you're really young at fourth grade for
some weird reason I was like I just
don't care about Saturn and I have a
funny feeling it's not gonna matter to
me
Wow there you go what about Uranus yeah
I care about Uranus that was set up so
perfect look okay I'm almost caffeinated
up to Gary Gary Gary Vee is here Gary
Vaynerchuk of course the CEO of the
world but we're about to get into the
meat and potatoes okay how this can work
for everyone I love it first of all I am
sick and F and tired of people calling
Millennials lazy and not caring and not
not wanting to contribute and I'm tired
of it because I don't believe it
I think everyone has an equal
opportunity to be lazy or dynamic you're
preaching I mean I get this all the time
because I have such a big fan base of 40
50 60 year old executives and like how
do you deal with these Millennials and
look look there's no calling them
Millennials there's no millenials
there's Rick there's Susan's there Sara
right I know unlimited 40 to 50 year
olds that are lazy and and have no Drive
and I have tons of 23 year olds that
work at vaynermedia that if I give them
$1 more an hour they'll work 72 hours at
a 24 hour day talk about it then 20 I'm
22 years old yeah my dad from from
college we should get into that racket
to begin with I'm 22 years old I've got
the world ahead of me I've got more
opportunity than most people so why I
branded a loser because old people want
to complain about the next generation we
become bitter so don't listen to them of
course not
so 22 year old let's say I'm 22 tell me
what I need to be doing right now to
make every 22 to 30 year old that's
listening just right now you have one
major flaw I'm generalizing you have
lack of patience Elvis if you really
want to talk about it what people are
making is they've got college debts
they've got their ambitions one of the
two let's say it's a positive let's say
it's a negative and they pop out a 20 to
23 and they take jobs that pay them 4000
dollars more for something they don't
want to do because they lack patience
Wow uh-huh that's the punchline my
friend like if you look at what you can
I can I can i how old are you 52 almost
are you blown away as I am as a 40 year
old man how young you feel oh yeah if I
told 25 year old Elvis at 52 you would
feel like this you know I feel better no
no these are the days when in Churchill
my favorite my favorite quote these are
the days and that's the punchline if if
I could wish anything right now I could
I would wish that everybody who's
listening that's under 30 could feel
what you and I feel right now I mean I
don't even feel like I've started you
know and so when you're 22 I remember
being 22 wasn't that that long ago
forties old I would have been like whoof
like
that would have like in that 18 years I
better have if I'm gonna buy the New
York Jets like I want to I better have
done it there now I realize my god
life is so long and the way we're taking
care of ourselves you know you're your
parents my parents at our ages they were
not as healthy they were you know we're
gonna live much longer we're gonna live
into our 90s hundreds like we have so
much time okay respect so so the punch
line the punch line in one way or the
other I would ask everybody who's
listening right now to take one step
back and say okay either I'm working too
hard and I'm stressing these loans or
what I have to achieve to prove to my
dad that I'm good
right and I'm not going to Coachella or
this and that or you're doing too much
of that stuff and you can work a little
harder but you've got so much more time
and so I think the one thing and it was
funny was that awkward pause that we all
just took patience is something we do
not talk about right now because if you
notice like I remember this is years ago
but back when Oprah was on and had her
show every day she did so many episodes
about young kids who are geniuses or
young kids who are 10 and already
graduated college and so in our society
we're being told that the faster you do
something the better you are the words
while i listening to society is a bad
idea if you listen to society the
world's on fire and we're all gonna die
if you listen to society everybody's
gonna build Facebook and snapchat then
who do we listen to all right yourself
listen to yourself now the problem is a
lot of us don't like what ourselves are
telling the inner voice can be a real
enemy that's right so so first and
foremost what what I think everybody
should do and even I'm saying this
action I'm giving myself advice right
now I'm just getting meta and stepping
away from this interview you need to do
things that make you a little
uncomfortable way too many people have
made decisions without ever trying right
so that that's one thing that I think
that's right and you have to taste
things like I love when people like oh I
hate sushi I'm like have you had it no
like right I know so and so to me that's
the most fascinating thing of how humans
are right like that's what we do and so
the punchline is this look here's what
here's what I'll say on this little
genres we're jamming on it you have one
life
like one of the great things that
happened to me growing up was there was
a lot of grandparents that visited I had
a lot of kids in my neighborhood and for
some unknown reason I don't know if I'm
an old soul or what it is
I used to on the playground go and sit
with old people yeah and just talk to
them and let me tell you one thing about
old people 8090 the one thing that is
stuck with me as a child and sits with
me today is they regret regret scares
the crap enemy Elvis do you have any
regret right now no but I also forty so
I feel like I can get a lot thing of
things done I feel like a lot of things
are still in front of me but when you
get to 80 and 90 and you can't do
everything and you know that you don't
have as much time with the one thing I
see in so many of their eyes is I wish I
everything I guess it is list they give
us the gift of these lists all the time
like you'll you'll have a health care
worker who works with people who are on
their deathbed they'll ask them give us
the top five things you regret from life
they tell us what they see that article
with the hospice worker you saw yeah it
really is fascinating we're gonna get
into that in a moment okay but Gary Vee
is here we're just getting started
we're just revving these engines up I
want to talk to you about the dream
everyone has if not working for the man
and doing it for themselves and how they
can use where they are now to catapult
him into where they want to go Danielle
about this in a few seconds ago Gary Vee
is here we'll be back with him with more
right after this
Gary Vaynerchuk is here Gary Vee we call
make sure you're following him
everywhere you can because every day he
gives us some thoughts that really
really catapult us into the day and
books yeah he's got books he's got
everything you don't want to be known as
a motivational speaker you're more of a
listen I've built a 50 million dollar
business and a hundred million dollar
business and I think a lot of people
when they hear motivational speakers and
things that nature reaps a sound it
creeps me out I mean somebody who I love
practicality look I'm very motivating I
understand that you know mom and dad had
sex at the right moment and gave me that
DNA I get that but I like that I didn't
start telling the world you can do it
until I did it instead of what we see on
Instagram which is 22 year old life
coaches trying to tell us what to do
it's kind of weird
usually when guests are here they have a
laundry list of things they want to
promote we were asking Gary earlier what
he wanted to promote today is like well
I'm not here to promote anything well
okay yeah I'm like let's get the callers
to call okay so we're gonna talk to Anne
Marie in one second but earlier you gave
us great advice we need to be more
patient in order to tackle life and when
what do you mean by patience we need to
be patient with what life like you know
everybody wants this car everybody wants
everybody wants to achieve
everybody wants these things first of
all we should want less things I think
that by the way you want a stereotype in
the other direction everybody
I think Millennials are the greatest
generation of not wanting big TVs and
watches and fast cars they they want to
go and experience things they want to
live a little bit of a better lifestyle
it comes down to this elves I think you
have to work hard like just so everybody
knows we haven't gotten into this
subject yet working hard is the cost of
entry to anything you know zero people
that are successful that don't work
their face off you know zero people now
they may have money cuz mommy and daddy
made money and gave it to them but
people that actually built their own
success you know zero people that have
had success that did not put in
obnoxious amounts of work very good
we're about to talk to someone about
that in just a second okay but dad
always said I'm thinking about these
great pieces of advice for my my father
who's passed away you can't have it all
where would you put it
were you gonna put it by the way real
quick I know we're going through the
call but I want to say this something
back to sha we talked about him when I
was on his show I talked about selling
stuff in your house on eBay I've gotten
50 to 100 emails in the last 30 to 60
days of people auditing their home
selling everything they didn't want on
eBay and people literally making a
thousand three thousand ten thousand
dollars to take a vacation on literally
just stuff like like an owl lamp
so everything was going so well in fly
referenceable damn we'll get rid of
everyone here every save good morning to
Gary Vee
what's on your mind today Anne Murray
good morning okay what kind of store do
you have loved it oh my gosh her
pretzels are amazing look you just took
the first step you're getting
advertisement only one of the biggest
shows in America Emory I think first of
all you you really saved yourself
because I was gonna razz you but you did
a great job I think Facebook at I don't
think your pretzel shop will ever spend
enough time and money on Facebook ads
and so I want to give you really good
advice because I want you to email me in
a year and say Gary you did it spend an
obnoxious amount of time on Facebook Ads
run a lot of ads within a one-mile
radius of your actual store I'm sure
you're doing online business are you
running Facebook ads are you spending
money on Facebook ads
spend money on Facebook ads cuz here's
my punchline as fortunate and there's
amazing as you've been you can be bigger
and better and so I would deploy a
certain percentage of your profits to
Facebook ads they will work and also
actually very economical Facebook
advertising is the number for everybody
who's listening right now Facebook
advertising is the number one deal in
marketing period in the world not in
social media not in digital in the whole
game and you got to celebrate something
Emory before we let you go the day you
signed your divorce papers and you open
your business to sign that lease the
most important day of your life I love
Emory thanks for hey before you take
another call yeah my takeaway today it
just makes my nipples so hard about what
garyvee said earlier yes look I could
cut glass with them holy yeah for
whatever reason the happy people on
earth are the most silent yes therefore
we only hear from the loud unhappy
people and it's doing something that's
awful to us in our in our lives
talk about I'm absurdly fix it we fix it
by going on one of the biggest radio
shows in the country and challenging
everybody who's listening right now that
if you're in a good mood
that's something smart to tweet about to
like why have we defaulted only to
produce in conversation around
negativity because let me tell everybody
who's listening right now what happens
people start believing that's what's
actually happening and so every day
every day ninety-nine percent of this
audience has good moments but they never
think about sharing that on Facebook yet
the second somebody cuts them off on the
road or the cashier is slow or they
don't like something that's happening in
politics they get nasty it's
rubbernecking and we have to start
talking positive because this is our
lives and we're we're going down a
slippery slope and so I think positivity
needs a momentum booster let me ask you
this Gary yes your opinion are there
more people who are happy or more people
who are miserable in life right now you
know what the best part is I'm not even
going to use my opinion the data
shows that more people are happy deep
amazing the world is crime is down you
know after the media wants to tell you
it's not right like so many things are
in great places right now now somebody's
listening saying easy for you that's
fine but you have to understand you live
in a country that allows you the chance
to get out of that like the market
doesn't care if you're poor you're black
you're white you're a girl like if those
pretzels are delicious they don't care
if an alien made it and that's what's
great about the market the market
doesn't care one way or another which
means you have a shot your parents may
be judging you your wife may say you're
a loser your neighborhood might say you
suck but the market that gets you out of
your situation it's actually not judging
you and that is why this is the greatest
time to be alive is that why our show
does fairly well if I can just toot our
own horn for a second we were probably
one of the only places to go where we
are amplifying happy and positive
thinking than everywhere else have you
ever heard of Oprah yeah like she did
okay so often now we'll come in and say
look we know a lot of crap is going on
we need to give you some posit let me
can think when crap was really going on
when our grandparents were alive there's
been this isn't crap this is not crap
guys we have it so good like like
everyone everyone thinks it's so bad
like Americans lived in fear that Russia
was gonna bomb us every day from 1950 to
1980 this is not crap they're not about
to bomb us well actually Putin's a
character it's true you know this is why
it's so important to study history
people wonder why history is such an
important thing to study it is because
you need to see where we've been and how
we got to where we are let's go talk to
Stephen Stephen say hi to Gary Vee
what's up hi Stephen how old are you see
this is a perfect you know this question
would have never been asked ten years
ago because of start-up culture and and
I'm not blaming you this is for
everybody who's listening everybody
thinks you need startup capital
right like where's my angel investor I
don't know any rich friends Steven I'll
be very honest with you if you're so
ambitious why don't you go out and sell
stuff on the side get a second or third
job sell stuff on eBay like you can
easily figure out a way to muster up an
extra five ten fifteen twenty thirty
thousand dollars by hustling extra I I
think if you don't have connections
that's your only alternative right like
if you do have connections great but to
really answer your question I think a
lot of people want to start this app and
they have this big idea but they what
they don't realize is they should go and
do something completely different to
muster up the dollars or back to
patients get two jobs eat crow
stop watching you know Game of Thrones
don't play Pokemon go go all-in for
three years and do nothing listen Steven
I did not have I did not have my 20s at
all all my friends now show up on
Facebook and they're like Gary you're so
lucky you're so lucky and I reply to all
of them I'm like I'm lucky let me remind
you something
remember in 1999 to 2009 when you went
to the Jersey Shore every weekend and
hooked up with chicks I worked so my
answer to Steven and everybody else is
if you're so ambitious show me no it's
not let me let Steven out and I'm not
trying to bus it here's my real question
if you really want it and by the way you
get to choose your work-life balance you
know that's on you like that's not me to
choose or anybody else what I'm
passionate about Steven to be very frank
with you is what can you do from Friday
5 p.m. until Monday 7 a.m. I'm just
curious like and I don't think you
shouldn't have a weekend but I think
everybody's ambition actually is more
predicated on their actions than their
words my friends tell me all the time
they're so ambitious and I'm like if
that's true then you punt leisure and
you punt concerts at Jones Beach and you
work Wow Steven best of luck to you
thanks brother thing to it yeah
sometimes these pills are hard to
swallow I only said and I think Stevens
a great guy and I didn't want to Steven
as a catalyst for a lot of people that
are listening I don't know Stevens
situation - just a dream no I think a
lot of people say that I ever say I
don't want to say that I'm ambitious
I want to show
you that I'm ambitious go watch my
snapchat Gary Vee and go watch my
snapchat and see that I'm up at 5:30
7:00 in the morning and see that I'm in
meetings at 11:58 p.m. there's no
question to Garrett if I'm if I'm
ambitious I'm showing you and so I just
think we live in by the way I think it's
so good in America that most people are
soft people like this easy people like
to say they're ambitious but look what
they do they say they look at the
negative hey I don't have connections
like some other guy or girl I heard of
that got $50,000 from people to start
their startup woe is me what was me
there's never been a generation our
parents our grandparents they never
heard of startup capital they work two
jobs saved money for seven years then
took the money they saved and risked it
and built a business GoFundMe was not
around
there was no good I'm gonna start a
Kickstarter and everything's gonna be
okay I love it I just also know the data
shows that 99% of the people don't get
their money again it's like I think a
screwdriver works but if you don't know
how to use it got it GoFundMe is a great
tool but do you have such a great idea
that America is gonna be excited to
write you a check so that you can do it
so I wish we had like another five hours
back tomorrow's is this over yeah almost
I know I hate that but no no no do me a
favor I feel like we're just getting the
East Coast huh storms going I think
people are like sitting at their desk
right now saying yeah I know it's like
foreplay with Gary Vee if we got a like
oh sorry I gotta go do something else do
me a favor really we're running a little
late but I want you to do something I
think it's very important Danielle's
husband Sheldon was saying you got to
tell the Jersey story about Tom give me
the Jersey tune this is actually a very
long story we'd have a lot of time
here's the punchline guys if you're
running a business actually for the
pretzel gal and everybody else Emery and
everybody else who's listening who has a
Ben
this Twitter twitter.com slash search
tell your story take your time on okay I
want to hear the story I wrote a book
several years ago called the Thank You
economy I've been on this kick for a
long time that positivity rules that
that's really where the action is and I
wanted to send somebody a gift as a
thank you for buying wine from
winelibrary.com so somebody places an
order and we find their name and we find
their Twitter account when we look at
their Twitter account and this is what
everybody can do you can go look up
people's names find their Twitter
account and then look at it and then we
looked at their tweets we saw this guy
loved the Chicago Bears and he kept
talking about the Bears quarterback Jay
Cutler just kept talking about it
talking about it so the guy placed $100
order that we made $13 profit on but I
told my team to send him a $400 signed
Jay Cutler Jersey on from ebay send it
to him and say thank you for being a
wine library customer right so the
punchline was he was gonna write back
and and you know tell us that he'll buy
all his wine from us for the rest of his
life that was my plan here's what
happens next
for three weeks we don't hear a thing so
I call my team I'm like have we heard
anything they go no I'm like son of a
gun this guy goddamn sure see where the
hell is he right you know super upset
then then did the duck all of a sudden I
give up on it I'm boarding a plane I get
a call from Wine Library and they go
you've got to see this I'm like what
happened I'm like the guy they're like
no I'm like BAM he goes better they read
an order that came in for thousands of
dollars of red burgundy and in the notes
section it says hey Wine Library this is
my first order just found out about you
first of all you have unbelievable
prices on red burgundy second of all I
live in Texas it's hot
please ship this order after the summer
PS I found out about you because you
sent my friend Steve a Bears jersey and
that's how I became aware of your
business
PSS I'm a huge Bruce Springsteen fan the
punch line is this of that story Wine
Library myself if you go look at my
account we give a waste
all the time surprise and delight find
out what people care about a lot of
times they don't write back I'm not
telling you the story about when I
bought the guy a ps3 and five games that
I never heard a peep from him right but
when you do the right thing
the right things happen everybody wants
to do something and expect something in
return I'm not interested in coming here
and promoting stuff I don't need to do
that I needed to come here and try to
give advice that a hundred people a
thousand people that are listening right
now got value out of and then that's
gonna work itself out for me one day
doing the right thing is always the
right thing and you can do that in
business and you can do that in life
god bless your parents for instilling
that into you because the obvious
question I give them absolutely the
circumstances of being an immigrant and
my parents are the reason I'm here
because of you like Thanksgiving he
gives all his clients pies for
Thanksgiving they get to pick a pioneer
this great pie giveaway but he does
these things and do you know what
happens yeah friends go to friends homes
they're like they're like you'll never
believe who gave me this great rhubarb
pie yeah excellent Gary Vee